what's in the mist and ending that
oversteps so here we go with another
entry in my cataloging of good or even
great movies that at least to my way of
thinking have bad endings and now I'm
gonna talk about one that I have cuttin
into a fair few arguments with people
over and that is the mist I'm talking
about the endings so you should
understand there's gonna be spoilers
okay here we go so the mist is a is a
horror movie based off a Stephen King I
believe it was a novella I don't think
it was a short story I haven't read the
original but so to lay it out in case
you're just here to watch me rant and
you haven't seen the thing it's a small
town in Maine of course it is it's
Stephen King and just a mist falls over
the town like really heavy and covers
the entire town and what ends up
happening is there are monsters in it
like weird strange monsters and like
really dangerous really deadly things a
whole chunk of the town basically holds
it up in the grocery store and they kind
of come apart at the seams things yeah
it does the whole sort of classic the
read the the true monster is the people
but there's there's also monsters
outside so at the end there is a small
group of I think there's four of them
there's our main character played by
Thomas Jane his son and two others they
managed to get out of the grocery store
where everybody was holed up they get
into a car and they just start driving
hoping to get out of the mist so they go
as they go basically go until they run
out of gas and Thomas Jane has a gun he
has a revolver it has three shots left
and with his son sort of resting his
head on him I think he's even actually
asleep and sort of looking back and sort
of just silently you know catching the
eyes of the other two and they everyone
kind of understanding what's going on
because they're out of gas there's no
sign of the edge of the mist they know
the monsters are out there and Thomas
Jane having promised his son earlier in
the film that he would not let the
monsters get him he shoots his son and
the other two people and then goes out
into the mist
and I have no problem with this this
honestly I think is perfect if it had
stopped right there you go to credits
with him going out into the mist
screaming trying to get the attention of
the creatures to end the pain of what he
just had to do but that's not where the
movie ended instead the movie keeps
going and because as he goes out into
the mist hoping that the monsters will
kill him what happens instead is the
army rolls up clearing the mist with
flamethrowers meaning that what he just
did was not necessary and if he just
waited probably literally two minutes
they would have been fine and I hate
that I hate it because it's a complete
overstep in an effort to sort of twist
the knife even harder with how much
misery
can we keep on it just is a step too far
and it broke the it broke the spell that
I had coz up to that point you know what
happened what he did in that car I'm
sitting there watching oh my god and
then this ending happens and I just went
you gotta be free
kidding me and I think and it this is a
milder version of it in this case than
some of the other ones I'll other films
I'll eventually talk about in this
series but I think that ending would
have been so much more powerful with a
sense of ambiguity with the assumption
that he goes that out and gets cut by
the monsters but we don't know what
happened to him after that and I think
that would have been so much more
powerful because it would have left the
audience with the sense of oh my god
what would I have done would I have done
that did he do what was under the
circumstances the right thing instead we
get an ending that by trying to make it
worse by trying to make it hurt more
confirms no he made the wrong decision
if he'd waited two more minutes
everything would have been fine what a
dumbass and by confirming that he in
fact made the wrong decision to me that
actually weakens the impact of the
moment it makes it a lot less impactful
and disturbing then it could go they had
an ending that was disturbing but by
bringing in this one extra element at
the end it goes from being disturbing to
simply being a cheap attempt at at being
I was gonna say sad but like that being
tragic tragedy is really hard to do well
it is I mean that that's a simple to
truth tragedy is a really hard needle to
thread cuz it can come off as stupid and
overdone melodramatic maudlin all
there's a ton of pit traps so I just
think it was a mistake for them to go
for that extra step to try for tragedy
when they had a wonderful sense of just
disturbing it was disturbing before that
happened and that just killed it that
killed it for me and it's and it's
maddening this is one of those movies
that like just the last few minutes
loses me it's not dissimilar to cabin in
the woods first one I did for this
series in that sense and that there's
something real
the infuriating about a film that would
have been great if it had just stopped
like three or four minutes earlier than
it did and that is my thought on the
mist and why the ending of that film I
think completely blew it so those are my
thoughts on it what are yours do you
think I'm crazy do you understand where
I'm coming from even if you don't agree
with me or do I just make absolutely no
sense that I might as well have just
been talking gibberish for the last
however long I've been talking whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
all the stuff to do such as like and
subscribe and follow me on Twitter
support me on patreon and much more
besides links for all that stuff's down
in the description so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]